what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to the lead attorney's
analysis on abbott and preach and fresh
and fit situation before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
especially if you've watched more than
three of my videos if you've watched
more than three of my videos and you
have not hit the subscribe button we
have beef
beef okay
anyways
um this
live i watched like half of it the other
day and it was the funniest thing i have
ever seen in my life oh my god i've
never been more entertained um so you
should go watch it the full thing if you
want on his channel
but
i just oh my god i needed to show this
to you guys okay
not to sound
so uh sorry i'm gonna move it back just
a little bit i don't really care if you
slump or not to me it doesn't really
matter to me
okay so this is kind of cutting in the
middle but he's talking about abbe and
preach are telling fresh and fit that
they don't care
if they stamp in the video that they
made
the only thing is that it's weird that
you are something
when you're telling all these men you
know not to simp and you know you're
beating up on all
you're beating up on all these women
verbally and all this and all that and
you're telling them not to simp
so uh
you know it looks hypocritical
which i will say and i you know i don't
abba and preach they do not
subscribe they do not count themselves
in the red hill community i've never
even heard them say
they're in the manosphere let me scoot
over a little bit i've never heard them
say they're in the manosphere
but they're like hey guys in the
manosphere i thought you guys were
supposed to be
accountable i thought you guys were
supposed to mean what you say and say
what you mean
you know it looks like that's why y'all
are [ __ ] all over the women you're
saying the women aren't being held
accountable
it's a little odd okay that's the weird
thing about the manosphere is people get
so butthurt
like
even this situation it all started when
adam preach made that video about fresh
and fit
about like a topic paying for box right
like he didn't say i hate you he didn't
say like
like i would not be offended if someone
said that they don't think that that
many hot guys want to date me like who
cares
if it's true who cares
um
which i would think is like the
equivalent of you know
not that you don't sleep with that many
girls which is basically what they're
saying i think that was like what pissed
them off
um and it's just funny because people
get so butthurt over criticism in the
manosphere and i'm a female guys
i'm a female like
shouldn't
like why am i saying this
anyways
that you guys are kicking women out of
your apartment because the women aren't
being held accountable but you yourself
are you know over here with only fans
and seeking arrangements and sugar
babies that's how y'all are meeting
y'all's girlfriends
right
well
when they made that video
it caught fire it blew up it went viral
i got the video tagged in the
description if you want to see it
donovan sharp did not like that video
he didn't like the video
all right
so he made a video kind of clapping back
so i'm like oh [ __ ] you know
uh this should be interesting this
should absolutely be interesting i want
to hear his arguments
so what i want to do guys is take a look
i want to i want to
take a look with you at some some
portions of this video i'm not going to
play the whole thing
but i want to i want us to hear it
together i want to know what you think
but i'm also going to tell you what i
think as this old grizzled
dog
of a of an attorney
and i want to let you know if i find any
of this persuasive
if it is persuasive i think it is
extremely valuable content
because we all need to be holding
ourselves accountable
if it's not persuasive
then we need to ask ourselves well
what is it for
why i don't know why he just cracks me
up
i don't know why is this made
you know is this the best
that can be made are there ulterior
motives
and i will you know this actually a
perfect segue let me let me bring this
up for a second let's see what we're
talking about here
let me uh let's see what we're talking
about
we got our man of the hour
also i'd like to say i actually really
like donovan he's coming on my channel
tomorrow so this is no hate to him at
all i like him but oh my god
this is the funniest thing i've seen in
forever
for the man we got donovan sharp
now
uh
he is unhappy about this video
so i want to talk about it
and i want to see you know what he says
and so what we're going to do is we are
going to
to uh start this thing off now we talked
a little bit before about the motivation
for this
let me let me tell you something about
attorneys
and juries
and judges
if you are on my jury
and we're in court you're on my jury
and i have a witness
that is against me
i'm going to cross-examine that witness
and one of the main strategies that we
attorneys use
is we go you know we can go straight for
the jugular and show what show that
they're biased
show that they're biased
why is it so important for attorneys to
show i think that everyone's biased
everyone has their own biases do you
guys think so let me know in the
comments that people are biased what
does it do
it does one thing
it just
decimates
your credibility
your credibility i mean it just leaves
it teetering now
you can be biased and tell the truth
just because you're biased doesn't mean
you're not telling the truth
but
it shades
your testimony
if you're gonna be biased
you better really be telling the truth i
mean that truth better shine
you know
when the when when when the gentleman is
35 and his con is on trial for murder
and they bring his mom to the stand and
the mom you know is 55 and she gets up
there with her cane because she's on
disability and she sits in the chair
the first thing she she the first thing
out of her mouth she want to say oh i
didn't raise him like that he couldn't
have done it he's my child
i know for a fact he didn't do it
fair enough
uh
what is your relationship
to to james
oh
i'm his mother
and uh i'm looking around the courtroom
and i'm noticing
i don't see i don't think i see james's
father in the courtroom is that right
that's right
uh where is james for i don't know
okay uh when is the last time you seen
james's father i don't know
so is it fair to say that you raised
james from you know from from from birth
all the way up by yourself yeah i raised
it myself
so you guys are pretty close then huh
yeah james is my only child
but he's only a child you you really
love him don't you yeah i love him more
than anything
and you would do anything for james when
yeah i would do anything
there's no limit to what you you would
do
for james no there's no limit
there's no limit to what you would say
james isn't no i would say anything
[Laughter]
get mom off the stand
get mom off this she'll say anything
right
who else
god i'm giving you game who else does
this you know who else does this
who
who do attorneys go straight after you
let me tell you who attorneys go after i
mean they go
straight after
co-defendants
people who are like turning states
evidence people who are snitching
oh
you want to snitch on my client
i'm going to try to show that you're
biased
i'm going to show that you were looking
at 20 years to serve
i'm going to show that the evidence was
stacked against you
then i'm going to show that you wrote
the d.a a letter
you wrote the d.a a letter
i've got information on james
after you testify today
you're you're going home are you yes are
you going home because of the deal you
made throwing james under the bus yes
you're biased
all right oh my god
i was talking about this with my
boyfriend once i
am in fact a snitch
i'll snitch on you like
i know
in um the rap community that's a really
bad thing they kill snitches
well i would be the first one to
what do they say six nine their ass
that's the guy he snitched right yeah
that would be me i'm not brave
if i got in trouble i wouldn't get into
trouble for anything i'm also what they
call a wuss
i'm pretty scared of things you know
it's not i'm not what they would say
brave you know so
yeah i'd snitch and i'd wish out
honestly
shout out to
uh the jury down in brunswick
convicted those men of murdering our
brother
ahmad aubry
there was only one black person on the
jury do you know why
do you know why i did a video about this
i'ma clip it do you know why so many
so many do you know why some black
people got kicked off that jury
because they were biased
because the uh
the judge was like
i want to get to the part where he talks
about donovan hold on
all
right
now no not a lot of their supporters
talked about it
okay
fresh and fit are exposed okay they're
scrambling
fresh and fit or exposed and they're
scrambling
i i i don't remember what i was talking
about but i had a live stream donovan
comes up
donovan comes up and the fresh and fit
stuff it was popping i mean it was in
the air everyone was talking it was in
everybody's mouth right
shout out to jessica x
uh
donovan came on the show and he was like
listen listen listen i'm coming on the
show to address this thing i am not
going to address the fresh and fit thing
i'm not going to address it
what was my reaction
right
i thought
i thought it made sense
because the stuff was still going crazy
and
he was not the only one
so many of uh fresh and fit you know
youtube supporters they were like
what's my thumbnail anybody know what my
thumbnail looks like
they were like what is going on because
no one really knew
stuff was coming out that their their
friends didn't know
so
everybody was like coach greg adams
coach greg adams has been on the fresh
and fit show
coach greg adams came on this show
in the summer do you know what he said
no no not a lot okay that's another
thing that i disagree with the man of
sphere on i don't think it's weak
to not say anything until all the facts
come out
like i don't
if i did something and got into like hot
water or got into some controversy and
my friends wanted to say stay silent
until all the facts came out
especially friends that you only really
see a couple times a year how often
unless they live by each other which i
from all indications that i've like seen
i don't think they do how often to like
rollo fresh and fit donovan sharp
who else is in that little like man gang
with that group how often do they really
hang out
at most they only see each other like a
couple times a year because they have to
travel to see each other
so how well do you really know people
that you've only seen a couple times a
year they could have a whole double life
that you don't know about
like
the only people you really know that
well are like childhood friends that you
grew up with
people that you live near
and live with
i'll die on that hill i'll die on it
nobody really knows each other that well
your supporters talked about it
so what donovan is saying on this clip
is like listen
that you know abba and preach exposed
them and she was going crazy
evan preached exposed them but i didn't
say anything
right
i didn't say anything about it
so he's telling you how he feels about
it let's take a look just real quick
what does he say uh let me go back a
little bit all right
and did i stayed mom on the situation i
should not have done that all right
this was absolutely one thousand percent
not the thing to do i essentially turned
my back on two of my best friends to
keep from getting any backlash so the
first all right
so what do we learn from that clip again
how often do you really hang out
just my two cents just you know but let
me
sorry donovan if you're watching this
i'm sorry
but i stand on it i do
i
cuz what fresh and fit have been in this
game so unless they knew each other
before they could have
but like fresh and fit have been doing
this for what two years year and a half
like you you haven't known them that
long
what do we learn
fresh and fit are two of uh donovan's
best friends
all right let's stop here for a second
talking about bias these are his best
friend do you remember when i have mama
on the stand
i'll do anything for my son
now we're gonna watch a reaction video
this looks so bad for the this looks so
bad from the manosphere it looks so bad
for trying to hold
accountability
to a high standard
all right now we got best friends
we got some best friend action
we got best friends trying to cover each
other
in the manosphere
[Music]
i don't care what anyone says this man
is so funny
i guess look at his facial expressions
okay
um so he says he felt bad about
being mom
when his best friends were were going
through it
even though so many other people were
the like going on over there
but those were his best friends
so he of course he feels a certain way
about it
now
you know what
why why why am i starting off with this
as an attorney and again
i'm telling you the importance of it
when you show that you're biased like
that when you have a co-defendant that
is snitching on you and turn states
evidence when you have mama on the stand
when you have
best friends on the stand
do you remember you remember that lady
down in brunswick
that lady in the ahmad aubrey trial and
she was testifying for the murderers
she was testified for the murderers when
she got off the stand she did this
number
it's like did you see that [ __ ] the way
that she was like
are you
everything you just said got wiped out
with the [ __ ] hand way
[Music]
right
it was ridiculous
it was like damn
that's how they doing it down here
where was her credibility after that
hand wave
where did it go
right
these men are on trial for murder and
you're testified and hopping off the
stand and waving at them
it was [ __ ] up
all right
now we have a reaction video from fresh
from from from
for from donovan about his best friends
right
he apologized
listen to what i'm telling you
he went back
and he apologized to fresh and fit for
staying silent
he said it was a [ __ ] move i'm
paraphrasing here because i don't
remember exact words but you know it was
feminine a [ __ ] move and this and that
i don't think it's a [ __ ] move
i think it's wise to wait until all the
facts come out
look it
i have a best friend since childhood
okay
since childhood
i've known her since i was in pre-k love
her to death but
we don't live in the same state
i don't know what she's doing she lives
in utah
i don't know what she's doing in utah
and if she came out about her
you know
i i don't think she would do anything
right i mean to my knowledge
she has never done anything like crazy
that would like get her arrested or like
publicly canceled whatever
but if if there started like
multiple people that don't know each
other started to have the same story
with the same evidence about her
i might wait it out
i would say yeah she's never done
anything weird like that around me
i've never seen anything like that but
how am i gonna say oh i know a thousand
percent
that she didn't do anything when ted
bundy had a whole family that didn't
know he was a serial killer they lived
with him
like
sorry my two cents
let me ask you a question if if he's so
if he feels so terrible if he feels so
terrible about staying silent the last
time
because they're best friends
what are the chances that he's going to
stay silent this time
zero
does anybody know the chances
what are the chances
all right but again now
we're going to talk about what he's
talking about but i'm trying to give you
guys some context this is how attorneys
look at things we look at it broad and
then we go down in right broad go down
in and we come out again it's like a
funnel and then you got it going down
and you got it going out right this is
the context
we already know we're on some shaky
ground
now if d and i'll be honest if donovan
would have said listen all of the stuff
i'm gonna say in this video is [ __ ]
but i'm just trying to support my best
friends
who has a problem with that
because then
it's clear
clarity
these are my best friends so i'm just
going to support them i don't give a
[ __ ]
i don't care about my channel i don't
care about my personal credibility i
care about blind loyally blind loyalty
to these two [ __ ]
as a man
as a man
just blind loyalty to these two
gentlemen
this is how i'm gonna use my channel
if he would have said that
you know
maybe people aren't as confused
all right
even as if you go look at his video even
his supporters were like what are you
saying donovan his own subscribers were
like what are you talking about
okay the lead attorney
you're hilarious this is my favorite
thing i've ever watched but we gotta get
back to the reaction we gotta this is to
my this is for my youtubers do not use
your channel like this
donovan has way more subscribers than me
donovan has been in the youtube game for
so long donovan knows how youtube
imagine working all this time and then
starting putting out content like this
right
youtube can be so difficult guys
and i know this because i'm counseling
you on it
i i have a i have two consultations
tonight
do not use your channels like this
uh you you're going to put in too much
work to throw away throw your
credibility away credibility guys means
everything
it doesn't matter if you're in the
courtroom like oh lead attorney you're
talking like you're in court we're not
in a courtroom fine
credibility matters wherever you are
it matters in the streets donovan is
from [ __ ] philadelphia right
philadelphia is a rough city
you don't think your reputation you
don't think your credibility means
something in philadelphia
what about the military yeah
philadelphia and and miami
no way no you can't
in two years different cities
that's what my dad would always point
out to me because my dad doesn't have
any social media
and one time i got cancelled it's a long
story um
it was actually really stupid but i got
cancelled on tick tock and everyone was
just spamming my stuff
they were just coming at me like on
twitter on my instagram just like
commenting stuff sending stuff to my
sisters like oh my gosh they don't even
know what it's like to actually be
canceled because tick tock cancelled is
like a different level of cancel and
um they even they messaged my old job i
was like i don't care i don't work there
anymore but like you guys are tweeting
at my old job
but i i hated that job so i could
go ahead um
i forgot where i was going with that
oh my god i literally forgot my point we
got some military men in the house shout
out to
hank tyrone from the 404 we got some
veterans
you don't think your rhetoric your your
reputation your credibility means
something in the military
[ __ ] what about in prisons
even on the prison yard
don't know a lot of places where your
credibility doesn't mean something
and so
when you when you say stuff like this
and when you do stuff like this
it can be hard to come back from
all right do not just listen what's the
upshot don't don't sell your don't sell
your credibility out guys it's gonna it
it takes you too long to get
shout out to uh daniel it takes you too
long to get
uh too much work
shout out to um
uh isos ice sosa frost thank you
uh
shout out to
jj would really appreci uh i really
appreciate that again i got to keep
going guys i can't read the the five
dollar one shout out to uh
uh joe
joe kim in really appreciate that thank
you
shout out to black wolf we got black
wolf in the house i already read that
one dinner
all right
um
all right what's going to his next point
let's keep it going guys we got 3 000
people in the chat you think i could get
a hundred more likes
yeah this is the funniest thing how many
views did this get i'm gonna look really
quick yeah 65 000. i have no idea if
that's good for him or not
oh my gosh she's almost at 100.
also i tried to get him to come on my
channel and i was in fact rejected um
it's okay though
not hurt does asking for likes even work
everyone says it does do likes even work
doesn't matter
let's keep it going uh so let's let's
let's look at let's kind of come down
we've talked about the context we've
talked about the bias we talked about
that they're best friends
all right
what is the first point that donovan is
making in defending is his best friend
all right let's
let's take a look at it let's see what
we got here let's see what we got
first thing i'd like to point out uh
about the situation
is the fact that these two still feel
the need to talk [ __ ] about fresh and
fit
now one would think that after they
successfully slowed down the train
that was clearly coming for them in
terms of audience and influence let me
my two cents
if you are charging people eight hundred
dollars for a course
the internet has a right
to
deep dive into whether we think you're
credible especially if you're in the
same sphere
like i don't i sell sweatshirts on my
channel which you should buy by the way
you know
my two cents but
um
like if i did
and you guys wanted to come at me and
say she's a girl like this advice is bad
that's bad um that's not
how she lives
i would not say oh no they're jealous
what that's such a female that's such a
female thing to do like imagine imagine
if a girl
went on to the onto the fresh and fit
show okay
and they said okay you're 28 um you have
like five years left i have i'm in a
better position than you because i'm
like whatever and the girl just said
well
you're just jealous of me like
everyone would be like
that's a terrible argument you know
that they would leave the situation
behind them congratulate one another on
a successful hatchet job and right off
into the sunset to continue to build
their audience
all right so what is he saying here
he says this
why are abba and preach continuing to
come at my best friends
why
they've already come at them before
you would think what did he say they
would just ride off into the sunset
if they've ridden off into the sunset
why are they coming back
we already talked about this during the
summer time
why are you coming at my best friends
that's an interesting point
um it's not acknowledging one thing it's
not acknowledging one thing did
abba and preach expose donovan's best
friends yes
yes
but you know
they were there's kind of like
various episodes it's not like
they came out
abba and preach exposed donovan's best
friends in the summertime
and are still talking about it in
november
they're not talking about what happened
in the summertime
what happened in the summertime was in
the summertime
they came out with a new
video about new events
the summer time is over guys listen
fresh and fit shout out to them they
admitted
all of their mistake you know here's the
thing
sometimes
there's darkness you gotta shine a light
and when you shine a light everything
comes out
fresh and fit were rocking and rolling
abba and preach shine to light
stuff started coming out
what was coming out errors
that fresh and fit were making mistakes
that fresh and fit were making donovan
even acknowledges
the errors
and the mistakes that that freshman fit
were making i mean they admitted to him
right
they admitted it let's
let me let's take a look let's see what
we got here
vernon fresh admitted hey hey we didn't
handle the situation well and we've
learned from it yeah
donovan says listen during the summer
time
they admitted we did not handle this
situation well
mistakes were made
thank you so much abba and preach
for shining the light
on our [ __ ] mistakes
all right we made them
[Laughter]
oh my god he could be a [ __ ] comedian
oh my lord now
let's get the sequence correct though
the sequence is important when do they
admit their mistakes
did they admit their mistakes before
alba and preach exposed them
or after
did they admit their mistakes before
alvin preached signed the light or after
obviously it was after
right
after abram preached exposed them now
they're admitting to all of these
mistakes
mistakes that even don of any knowledge
is hey they admitted to them they were
making them let's see what donovan says
man they admitted that hey you know what
we mishandled the situation
right myron's like look dude hey
shouldn't have gone after the guy's wife
blah blah blah
so now here's another thing too
once
abba and preach expose them for who they
are
they admitted their mistakes but they
were trying to hide them at first they
were trying to you know
circle the wagons
and encircling the wagons in doing the
cover-up they made more mistakes
and this is what donovan is referring to
when
uh
fresh no when uh
what's the tall dude's name
what's he told his name
fit when the fit guy he went at
i was uh no he went at preach's wife
everybody knows that was [ __ ]
everybody
but he did that because he was
scrambling
fresh and fit were scrambling they were
losing subscribers they were scrambling
so not only were they committed oh my
gosh and the funniest thing i was there
during this whole time because i went on
their podcast like
a myth like oh my gosh i can't talk
during this whole thing
and when they were talking they were
like
they're like
oh well they're commenting like it
boosts engagement so who cares and you
know people like say that you could just
tell they don't like they clearly don't
mean it and then i forgot what they're
just kept saying like oh it's because
everyone's jealous it's because
everyone's jealous of us and i'm just
thinking like
why does
why is that the go-to in this community
sometimes people just don't like you for
whatever reason
like is that it was no where none of you
bullied as kids
my first thought when people don't like
me has never been i've never understood
this mindset like it's more um
when someone's like mean to you it's
about them not you i've never really
believed that no never or um they're
just jealous of you no
because what i'm i'm a pretty nice
person i'm pretty polite
but
when i'm not nice to someone usually
it's because i don't like something
about them
it's not about me
it's something about their personality
that could be
better and if you were bullied as a
child or at least excluded from things
not invited to parties
you would know that very clear
there was some stuff wrong
with who i am
who i am as a person
i can live with that
not only did they get exposed for making
mistakes but then they made further
mistakes in the cover-up and that's what
donovan is saying donovan was like hey
listen man
fit admitted to to making even more
mistakes and talking about the man's
wife and stuff like this fine
like
alvin preach how many how many
admissions of mistakes do you want
you expose them
then they try to do a cover-up and
they're making all of these mistakes but
they've admitted to them
why don't you just leave them alone they
did a five-hour stream
admitting to mistakes what is uh what
does donovan say
a five-hour livestream explaining all
that had happened
took full responsibility for their
missteps yes all right
they did a five-hour stream abbott and
preach get off these [ __ ]
they did a five-hour stream admitting to
all of their mistakes what do you want
right
oh my gosh yes
i'm laughing now i've already heard this
but the first time i watched this i was
crying i thought it was so funny my room
was trying to
exchange sex for collabs
where's my vivid life
that was rude
i do like my vivid life though she's
super
cute um
yes they made mistakes
they did a five hour stream they were
trying to leverage leverage the the sex
for the collabs
myron shot a shot at anna quinn he
admits that this was foolhardy on his
part you live and learn so even though
fresh and fit stumbled in the beginning
which is completely understandable given
then they're like
why does he call it shooting his shot
and stumbling
you know what
i've been on youtube for a minute i i'm
not nearly as successful as i need these
people
but i would not call it stumbling
if i said hey can i come on your show
i'll have sex with you
i i would call that a decision but you
know whatever lack of experience they
quickly adapted and lack of experience
aren't they in their like mid-30s
how can you be in your mid-30s and not
think like hmm
that might not be a good idea like i
would not blame that as a lack of
experience
i blame like who you are as a person
am i the only one that struggles with
low self-esteem
like that is my i don't know
i guess i guess the man of sphere does
teach confidence so preserving their
hard-earned reputation as the number one
dating podcast in the world
all right so what does he say
he says listen guys they made all of
these mistakes what did you hear me did
you hear what he said he said you live
and learn
all right you live and learn
what you know the living part is clear
what about the learning
the learning part is where it looks a
little bit
a little bit sketch right it's the
learning part have they learned
what have they learned
all right i mean if if abba and preach
are talking about this again what
exactly
have they learned let me give a quick
shout out big shout out to
rough day one says thanks for all of the
great content
i don't agree on the street rules
subject
i don't know about street rules
i missed that
uh but thank you i appreciate that
uh and thank you as well to mosaic shout
out to mosaic with tj randolph excellent
content creator one of the mods could
drop her channel
all right
so yes you live and learn but they've
learned now
right
so
abba and preach are back at it again
now
donovan said live and learn who can
learn from this
who can learn from all of these goddamn
mistakes
that fresh and fitter making well
obviously fresh and fit can learn from
it who
else all of the men that they are trying
to serve
all of the men that they are trying to
serve
some of those men they have half a
million subscribers
some of those men can want to start
youtube channels what if they learn
don't exchange your channel for [ __ ]
how have they learned that
through myron gains
who exposed that lesson to myron gaines
abba and preach
abba and preach
i mean donov is an older man like me
right he's not in his 20s donovan knows
that you know
collabs for [ __ ] is
come on
if they're not in there okay if if
donovan is right if donovan is saying
these are my best friends you should
want the best for your best friends
you should want your best friends to
have the knowledge that they need and
you should be thankful in the way that
they get it
right
abba and preach exposed
fit to some very critical information
nowhere did i hear donovan thank abba
and preach
for teaching
his best friend that lesson
that lesson if he had not learned it it
could have gone down another way
it out i mean things could have gotten
way uglier
than what than what they did
but not only
not only did so not only did fresh learn
a lesson
but half a million other people minimum
learned a lesson too
what are we about in the manosphere
i told you when i [ __ ] a pregnant
moose
many
men were like jesus that has happened to
me
i get comments all the time guys you
guys don't know how many comments i get
that says where was your channel five
years ago
where was your channel 10 years ago
where was your channel when i needed you
i get comments like this every day on
these videos
this is what the manosphere is for to
teach lessons
these are very critical now it was
embarrassing
that i had sex with a pregnant moose it
was embarrassing
that
fresh and fit got exposed for who they
are but everyone else is learning from
it donovan
everyone else is learning in the
manosphere
this is so important
now let me go back a little bit because
donovan says you know he mentioned also
that
these people were these fresh and fit
characters you know they were being
transparent and taking accountability i
think that's what he said what did he
say stumbled in the beginning which is
completely understandable given then
their lack of experience they quickly
adapted and they ended up preserving
their hard-earned reputation as the
number one dating podcast in the world
they came correct they were transparent
and effectively stopped the hemorrhagic
when this all right they were
transparent
they were transparent
about all the fraud and all the mistakes
they were doing they were transparent
when
oh my gosh this is the best point he
makes
oh my gosh i'm i'm gonna let him go i'm
gonna let you do you okay when were they
transparent
oh
when abraham preached got on the scene
when abba and preach got on the scene
now as donovan's was saying his best
friends are transparent
do you get a pat on the back for that
they were transparent it's like
that's like finding screenshots of
someone cheating
and then after they're like okay i'm
gonna tell you everything
and they tell you everything but it's
like
but when
you told me you told me after not before
or like after i found evidence not even
after you did it
you're sitting in the cop car with
handcuffs i did it you're in the car
we know you did it
we know you did it
you don't get
you don't get credit
for admitting you did it
when you are arrested months later and
you're in the back of the patrol car
with handcuffs on
i did it take the handcuffs off
you win the car
i'm being transparent
of being transparent officer
come on
come on the only reason you were being
transparent is because fresh and fit
helped you out a little bit
fresh and fit helped you out a little
bit
and now you are transparent
who should give
who should get the credit for you being
transparent
who should get the credit for you
admitting these mistakes is it you
or is it abba and preach
right do you guys see a pattern what i'm
trying to show you is a pattern
there's fraud
there is exposure
and then there's admittance
fraud exposure
transparency where is the transparency
it's after the exposure
all right and this is
this is why i take advice from my dad
because
i know my dad is more
successful
than anyone on youtube
and
he could give advice for thousands of
dollars and make like a living doing
that
well
i don't know if he likes people enough
but you understand what i'm saying
and i get it for free
so why on earth not everyone has that
though so i get trying to find people on
the internet to like follow
but my dad always said that like
people that go into this industry like a
lot of times
are frauds he would always say that
actually not about youtube he would say
that about public speakers that he hated
public speakers because half of them
like
got their own like [ __ ] messed up anyway
i keep saying what's donovan's main
point donovan is like listen
why are you coming after
my best friends when they've already
been exposed what's the problem with
this thinking
what's the problem with that thinking
that they've already been exposed so
this should just be laid to rest
it hides the fact
that
fresh and fit
keep making mistakes
there's new stuff donovan
they you know this video that evan
preach did it's not about the august
stuff
it's about the november stuff
there's new stuff
it's the whole point
abbott and preach would not be making
videos about this whole symphony thing
if it wasn't new album and preach would
not be making videos about the the white
girl if she would have came out in
august it's new
eighty percent oh my gosh and that's the
annoying thing people will be like why
do you keep talking about them why do
you keep making videos on them
it's exactly what he's saying with new
information
like
and especially
the crazy thing is
is fresh was saying on his um
on the rollo tomasi show or whatever he
was saying oh well it's every time we go
viral
then people make a video because they're
jealous right
when your clips go viral more people see
them
so
obviously
there's going to be more people
out of that like
let's say a million more people see your
videos you don't think one person out of
the million that see them
is he gonna find something they don't
like
like i don't know why every the madam
sphere is so weird when it comes to
jealousy like when people don't like me
i always think it's me
or something like they don't like about
me i'm not saying this is what i'm not
saying you don't need to change for
every person that doesn't like you you
don't even need to appease people that
don't like you
if people don't like me i just keep it
moving
if it's the same you know trait that
people keep saying about me they don't
like i might do some self-reflection
i don't know but
that's just growing up
when you were bullied this damn content
creators in this space make content
about what's new
right
but
but
donovan's like well my best friends we
already talked i've been preached you
already exposed them in august why are
we talking about it again evan priestly
already admitted their mistakes over and
over and over why are we talking about
this again that stuff was in august yes
donovan this is november
so his point is not really making any
sense
because there's new stuff
guys this is like if i rob a bank
if i rob a bank
three years ago
and get arrested
well that's robbing a bank right so
let's say i rob a bank
15 years ago and i do seven years
i do seven years then i rob a new bank
and they arrest me again
and i'm like what the [ __ ] you arrested
me again this is
you already arrested me
i did seven years
you're so funny back in august
yeah but
you robbed a new bank
this is old stuff
right
that's what he that's what he's missing
it's new [ __ ]
i don't know like as an attorney it's so
clear to me like is this clear to y'all
it's so cle when i heard there's always
like donovan
you know
but again i'm not holding him to a suzet
standard i'm not holding him to an
attorney standard i'm holding him much
lower
but to me if people keep making mistakes
you can keep talking about it right you
can keep holding them accountable
is it to be honest is what they do
in the in the whole red pill community
space
so
if fresh and fit
[ __ ] up again in next february
abbott and preachers will say oh i
talked about this in august
why is donovan's why is donovan saying
this stuff like this oh
he said they're best friends
all right
and again
we're going to move on to another point
but i just want to i just want to make
it clear that this space is for us to
learn
and if donovan is true
about
not just [ __ ] on women but about
really helping men
then donovan should want men to know
the truth about things
right
and so just like this blind loyalty to
his best friends
i don't i don't really understand it
right shout out to uh
shout out to eddie p
thank you so much eddie p
says uh
donovan had another video at a different
angle and there's a photo of myron on
his wall
yeah he already said that they're best
friends he already said that they're
best friends shout out to uh simeon
hardin really appreciate that shout out
to lynx
said men whole men accountable period
point blank
absolutely
adult adolescents cover for each other
thank you so much links really
appreciate it i'm glad you guys are
picking up what i'm putting down because
i want to be serious about this right
shout out to uncle stu shout out to
uncle stu what does uncle stu say
integrity and honor mean everything
okay and that's
why
i don't agree with cheating if you have
some sort of agreement with your
significant other
fine but if you're gonna lie to the
person that's helping you raise your
kids the person that you love supposedly
like how how is anyone supposed to trust
you
anyone
and even with the fresh and fit thing
like you could see how hurt that girl
was after she heard the way that fresh
talked about
her on the live stream
um because clearly she at least thought
they had some basic level of respect
being like friends you know friends with
benefits whatever
um
and then he's out like talking about how
bad her head is how she's not even that
good at sex like that is
not that is not the way you talk about a
friend
so
i don't know it's like it's a character
thing
this is what we in the military live for
and die for honorable discharge means
any means everything honorable
honorable
right
um
thank you so much uh
jonathan and thank you gail
y'all like man slow to chat down
of course i read this 30 minutes too
late right
um
and thank you jonathan uh jonathan said
that uh abbott and preacher in the
building
we got abbott and preach in the building
shout out to these brothers
shout out to the brothers let me slow it
down what y'all think about 35
35 good i don't want to do this again
let's just do it 40.
shout out to alba and preach in the
building
um
i should not have done that
guys when you uh make changes on the fly
you can absolutely get thrown off thank
you so much uh before uh
uncle stew the old man on the block
if one of the mods could please drop his
channel i am subscribed to him i
actually did a collab with him the other
day excellent content creator thank you
so much uh why
we got some wyatts down here in georgia
thank you so much uh tyra
really appreciate that thank you so much
okay he's going on about the super chats
but i just had a thought okay the lead
attorney
i'd really like to have you on my
channel this is what this is what he did
okay
he goes i don't think we have a lot of
the same viewers
and so i sent him a screenshot because i
could see what other channels
my subscribers watch
and like one of them was his
so i'm like no i think we do he left me
on scene look it i understand i'm a
small youtuber over here
he's close to a hundred thousand subs
he's making bank clearly qualified to
talk about anything i'm just like the
whitest girl on earth that's my youtube
persona
he's like a 20-year divorce attorney
like what
we're not on the same youtube level
people follow me like i think because
i'm entertaining i'm a little funny kind
of awkward they follow him because he
knows his [ __ ]
okay
so i understood being left on scene but
hear me out
i plan on being on youtube for a while
at some point i'm gonna keep bothering
you i'm gonna keep dming you i moved to
england so i've i've laid off
like respectfully i'm going to keep
dming you so at some point
i feel like you should just come on
but you know
i'll i'll let you decide
reckless gaming we got reckless gaming
in the house i'm just gonna uh shout out
a couple more then i'm gonna get back to
it because we're
we are far from done and i want to just
show you guys how i
can't find it but i can see it up here
stream yard changes
scare me
this is a gentleman who calls out scams
this is a gentleman who knows y'all go
check out pocket watcher with jt
excellent brothers excellent brother we
have done numerous collaboration we're
going to do another one once i
you like
beat it up to like 135
he had to manipulate it so much
why
oh because youtube will take away your
money
um
yeah
why did donovan have to manipulate all
of that
because alba's got a day of uh heat
seeking algorithmic missile to locate
his content listen i did oh my god okay
it clearly is not that good because i
have definitely reacted to a lot of
their content and i do it more because i
don't get copyright strikes
um evan preach if you watch that i doubt
they will but on the off case they do
please please just let it
don't start copyright striking them i
try to like make it my own content and
like react and offer enough commentary
but like
you know
people copyright for everything reaction
is a hard niche
because you lose a lot of money just
because like one of my most viewed
videos i don't even get paid on oh my
god that's why i stopped doing music
reactions one of my most viewed videos
i get no money over a hundred thousand
views
sorry i'm i'mma keep going i did a
collaboration with those brothers
and i uh told you know
you talk to an attorney and you say hey
attorney tell me one of your crazy
stories if you ask a 20-year attorney
for a crazy story you're gonna get what
you asked for right so in my head i was
like i should not tell this story
because it's on the one hand it's messed
up
on the one hand it's [ __ ] up
and on the other hand it's funny
right now i'm only speeding it up till
he gets back to the donovan if i'm gonna
collab with you i can't tell that story
because we're gonna laugh and we're
gonna get canceled but alba is different
do you guys know what albert is he's
made right faster one of the things that
abba is is he's a comedian comedians
have a license they have a license to
laugh at anything they can laugh at
anything
because you can always fall backwards
hey i'm in the community all right you
can't come down so when i told that
story we were laughing about it i
thought i was uneasy laughing about it
because we all know this publicly but i
got uneasy about it but i was like i'm
in the presence of a comedian so you
know i can i can i can ride the
coattails of his privilege his community
privilege
we did a collab i didn't see i didn't
see where the video went then a day or
two later i saw a clip of the effed up
portion i saw just a small like 10 15
minute clip so i was on another channel
so i'm watching the damn i'm watching
the clip on someone else's channel right
when it gets to the good part
gone what does it say youtube is like
this content that's been recognized and
restricted by alba i was like i was
watching it how could you
it's me
like how can you restrict me from me i
was watching the damn thing
right so
their whatever whatever machine or
company media company that alba uses
to find his content that company finds
it
so that's why uh your boy
your boy donovan had to turn everything
around and manipulate it all so that
hopefully hopefully
uh abba abbas media company wouldn't
find that damn thing
because i was watching my own story and
they they absolutely found it i
absolutely found it shout out to j.m
penderson says uh abba and preach
prosecuted
fresh and fit and their transparency
came after
their allocation when they
reviewed all of the evidence presented
against them absolutely jm penderson is
absolutely right you don't get any
credit for that donovan
all right
shout out to uh bam slaughter really
appreciate that bam
so
all right so let's let's get back to
donovan for a second
thank you oh my gosh i'm really not
trying to like react to this whole thing
but it's hard because he
it's like not in one piece it goes like
back and forth we already know that abbe
and preach made that video
in the summer exposing
now they've made another video because
new [ __ ]
has come out
so donovan is like okay okay
why are you
really
why are you really making this video
against my best friends
and if you're new to the stream guys
this is not me like trying to be funny
calling him best friends i played in the
very beginning of the video if you're
new we got
3 300 people in the chat
donovan sharp said that uh fresh and fit
were two of his best friends and he had
to apologize to him for staying silent
in the summer
now it's the winter donovan has an opera
a new opportunity now
he was silent in the summer and he
apologized to him he said he felt like a
[ __ ] and you know was feminine and all
this
and he said how can i stay silent you
know
when you know
and and not support my two best friends
two of my best friends
so this uh this these are his words he's
he's calling him best friends this is
not me
donovan is like why are you coming after
my best friends he starts to assign a
motive
all right
now
what is the motive
what's the in the in the mana sphere
what is the motive
of calling out women's [ __ ]
right one is that so men can really see
how women are another motive is so that
women can start taking some damn
accountability yep that's what i was
saying earlier
they'll say the same like
they'll say something to women and if
you point out something about them well
they're just jealous
what the no
for their
their actions their words their lives
so many women call in to kevin samuels
and get
accountability rammed up their ass
it's rammed up their ass
this is a huge motive for this space
a huge motive for the manosphere space
is accountability
it's so easy for men
for donovan
to hold women accountable
all right
fresh and fit exposes
abba and preach and they apologize
they admit their mistakes
abba and preach expose them again
what do you think the reason is
probably the same reason that happened
the last time
right
no no donovan says no that's not the
motive this time
the motive this time the motive now when
i have the chance to speak about my best
friends the motive is different it's not
about accountability anymore
the motive is about
marginalizing
my best friends
the motive is about defaming my best
friends the motive is about slandering
my best friends that's the real motive
if donovan was talking to a woman though
it would not be about marginalization it
would not be about defamation it would
not be about slander it would be about
accountability but since it's these
brothers coming against my best friends
so
it's a little different
right it's funny how if you just take
out his best friends and put in women
it's totally confused totally reversed
it all makes sense if it's women the
only time that this doesn't make sense
is when it's when if it's when it's with
donovan sharp's best friends
if women were pulling this [ __ ]
it would all line up
right
what does he say about what does he say
about
uh the
purpose why is it that abba and preach
are really coming after his best friends
what's the real meaning let's see
whole thing started make no mistake the
intended objective was to marginalize
defame and slander fresh and fit for the
express purpose of destroying their
credibility and subsequently their
audience and it actually worked for a
little while all right so you have
donovan
assigning
assigning a motive
to
abbe and preach saying no no no you came
after my best friends because you wanted
to marginalize them you wanted to defame
them you wanted to slander them
what's one word that we're not hearing
at all
accountability
you say well lead how do you know it's
accountability well what happened in the
summer
and the thing is you absolutely have a
right
to look at their dating
like what they do when they are dating
if they are teaching dating
if i was
selling you a cooking course wouldn't
you want to look at how i cook
and
if i'm selling a cooking course
and then you find out i hello fresh
everything
which is like cooking for bad cooks
i'm one of them i know
i'm trying to get better though that's
what i'm trying to learn while i'm in
england is how to cook but
yeah like i think
it it makes sense
for you to look at
what you sell
and i don't understand why this is
controversial
aren't i supposed to be the emotional
one
i'm the female
in the summer fresh if it exposed them
and they took accountability
in the summer fresh and fit expo no ava
and breach there's too many guys in the
summer abba and preach exposed fresh and
fit and fresh and fit took
responsibility
abba is preached expose them
transparency
expose them
accountability
now it's november
abba and preach are exposing them again
what is the motive
oh slander oh okay all right now
[Laughter]
now is slander all of the sudden
oh my god in the summer it was about
admitting stakes in the summer it was
about transparency in the summer it was
about apologies in november it's
defamation
you don't have to be an attorney to know
this [ __ ] doesn't add up
you don't have to be an attorney
right
what do we got here we got millennial
mart tv in the house shout out to
millennial mark excellent content
creator talk about somebody gonna get
the bag says shout out to the lead
attorney just joining in hope this isn't
another beef going on within the mana
sphere dropping love on the stream no
this ain't even beef man he's brought
everybody in sorry i cut it a little bit
absolutely everybody
uh this space i'm trying to skip over
the super chats would not be
where it is without this man it wouldn't
exist let's just tell you how judges and
juries view credit not only did o'shea
bring oh my god i tried to get ocean on
my channel too and i was in fact
rejected um yeah
donovan sharp into the space
o'shea brought me into the space
he's brought everybody in
absolutely everybody
uh this space would not be
where it is without this man it wouldn't
exist let's just be honest it wouldn't
exist
so many youtubers i'm helping if you you
see you see some of the super chats
they're saying oh lee thank you so much
for helping me with my channel
nobody would say that if it wasn't for
o'shea
because o'shea helping other people with
their channel gave me the idea
to help other people
before i i hooked up with o'shea i did i
was like i just focus i was focusing on
my own channel like everybody else how
do i get subscribers up how do i get
these goddamn views
i wasn't studying anybody else
it just didn't come to my it's not my
[ __ ] it just didn't come to my
it just didn't come to my head
but thanks to o'shea he really set a
pattern he absolutely did and there are
a lot of people a lot of small youtubers
who he has no idea exists but they have
benefited from him through me
so he is helping
another generation of youtubers that he
hasn't even seen yet
right that's how that's how strong this
man is
um
shout out to him again what does oshay
say he says uh
deserves every [ __ ] penny every
[ __ ] penny and i know listen this
challenge
because you know over the weekend this
week there has been some rumblings in
the space
shout out to mosaic
okay i'm sorry sorry guys ah
okay
now that you're coming home at my best
friends and now that i have a chance to
respond this is about
marginalizing my best friends this is
about defaming my best friends this is
about slandering my best friends
that's what he said he said this is
about destroying their credibility
all right just to just to refresh our
memories of what he what he said here i
know we got caught up with the super
chats and are fresh and fit for the
express purpose of destroying their
credibility and subsequently their
audience
let's take it a little bit further back
so you guys hear what we're talking
about we stopped the hemorrhagic when
this whole thing started make no mistake
the intended objective the intended
objective let's hear what donovan says
is the intended objective of this
even though fresh and fit called him out
over the summer and they had to
apologize eve even though adam preached
even though albert preached exposed
fresh and fit in the summer and fresh
and fit apologized even though alba and
preach exposed fresh and fit in the
summer and and fresh and fit became
transparent
even though fresh and fit exposed album
preach exposed pressure fit in the
summer and fresh and fit admitted to
their mistakes
what is the purpose now in november
what is the purpose of abba and preach
exposing fresh and fit in november
was to marginalize defame and slander
fresh and fit for the express purpose of
destroying their credibility and
subsequently their audience and it
actually worked for a little while
is anybody believing this
there's 3 000 people in the chat is
anybody believing this was the purpose
oh in november you guys were right but
now in nov
in summer time you guys were right in
november it's about marginalization
did you guys catch something too did you
catch something
did you catch
let me [ __ ] play it back because this
is very important
let me play about for you guys so you
could you can hear it
what he said
what was the express purpose listen to
the express purpose
the express purpose of why
abba and preach are defaming fresh and
fit listen to the express purpose
was to marginalize defame and slander
fresh and fit for the express purpose of
destroying their credibility and
subsequently their audience and
destroying their credibility
what did we talk about you can't destroy
someone's credibility unless they have
something that makes them look
uncredible
and i will give credit to the lead
attorney like some of these arguments i
did not think as i was watching that
live stream
until like later
and then later like he he lays it out
beautifully
oh my god this is the funniest thing i i
wish you could have gotten my initial
reaction like when i watched this for
the first time because it was on my
phone you know i didn't like pull
anything out and i only watched like
parts of it but i was laughing oh my god
i was laughing so hard
this man is so funny about for the first
20 minutes of this damn chat
we talked about bias
and credibility
this shows you this is not a dominant
dome mouth this shows you that even
donovan understands the importance of
credibility
so now we have a contradiction
because how can credibility be so
important
to fresh and fit
how can credibility be so important to
men
and yet donovan puts up this [ __ ]
blind loyalty video with
with these arguments
i thought credibility was so important
but where
this video what is it doing to your
credibility when you announce all of
your bias you're saying these are my
best friends
i had to apologize to my best friends
that i didn't defend you guys in this in
the summer
i told my best friends that i was a
[ __ ] in the summer for not defending
you guys i just laid it out
and now there now here you are in
november
you don't think you're
i don't think you're a little biased
you don't you don't want to go back and
apologize again
that's the real that's the real
reason this is going on and
you don't want to apologize again to
your best friends what did you say live
and learn
you want to show your best friend these
two dudes
fresh and fit you want to show these two
dudes that you've lived and learned
fine
these two dudes think you're cool
what about your credibility as a man in
a in society
two people let's be honest two people
don't really give a [ __ ] about you can
we be honest
these two gentlemen
versus your credibility
on youtube
these two gentlemen oh my god that's
what i'm saying like how well do you
really know them
genuine like how
this is why it's so important to have
friends in the real world like this
youtube bubble is cool and all but like
it is genuinely important to have
friends and connections and
relationships in the real world because
none of this stuff is real
it's not those aren't the people that
are going to be by your side throughout
life they're just people on the internet
like we're not
even people that watch me i love you
guys but i don't i don't know you
and i feel like
the internet i gotta stop saying i feel
like because the man of spirit always
comes for me the internet gives you a
false sense of closeness closeness with
people that you don't really know that
well because the people that know you
super well
are the ones that call you out the most
honestly
versus the credibility of your channel
now it could very well be that donovan's
like hey these are my best friends and
[ __ ] my youtube channel
i'm ride or die for my best friends
okay
that could be the case
you know
these two dudes mean so much my
credibility as a person means nothing
because they would do it for me right
they would do it for me right fresh and
fit would sell their asses for me
fresh and fit wit
would sell their asses for donovan sharp
they would do it for me right
we're best friends
fresh and fit would give up the
credibility of their channel for me
fresh and fit would give up their money
for me
freshman fit would give up the lambos
they would give up the rolexes they
would give up the hoes for
me we're best friends lead
fresh and fit would give up their
credibility for me
all right
say okay
all right donovan
let's look at another motive
this is about you know it was not enough
just the slander and the defamation
right what else does he say
he says uh guys you ever this is
actually talk about what women do
[ __ ] women
shout out to
all the women in the chat
i i told you if we got new people if we
got new women in the chat this is the
inside joke you had to be here in the
beginning
but you know we had april mason on we
have women on all the time
this is men's day you ever been to the
church in this men's day
we're talking about some heavy hitters
in this space we're talking about
donovan sharp
abba and preach fresh and fit we're
talking about some real men
all right
you ever been yeah you ever heard a
woman say oh you know
i've got my phd and he's men are
intimidated
men are intimidated by me
right
that's why i'm that's why i'm not
getting the results that i want that's
why i'm getting criticized
yes this is what i'm saying where are
the people with low self-esteem
when i'm criticized
look it
i figure i probably did something
like okay my freshman year in college it
was so funny because my roommate and
this was when yik yak was a thing
and um someone put me and my roommate on
blast like they said i forgot what
hers was like really stupid like she had
um
a disabled like pass near the door
and um her knee like healed but she
still had the pass for like another
month and in college it's like a gold
mine like if you have the disabled spot
then um
like like parking is so hard to find it
was it's a gold mine and at that school
anyways um and it wasn't like she was
taking it from someone else because they
made that spot for her
um because we were in the all girls
dorms so there was it was like a small
it doesn't matter anyway second yik yak
was about me
and they called me a [ __ ] and i was
just thinking like did i do something
[ __ ] lately
probably i wasn't like oh they're
jealous of me no i probably did
something to piss them off
let's be humble guys
like seriously
because you know
men are men are intimidated but i'm such
a powerful woman
we see this all the time no you're
probably the problem
like sometimes in life you're the
problem
it's okay
like what
why
why is that so hard i'm in the man of
sphere
all the time you know what is what is
what does donovan say what does donovan
say about this and it actually worked
for a little while preach are clearly
intimidated by the rise of fresh and fit
these
abba and breed
and preach are clearly intimidated
you know talking about lawyers lawyers
fall into this trap new lawyers
new lawyers when they're writing briefs
new lawyers when they're writing motions
do you know what new lawyers always do
it takes a year to beat this out of new
lawyers
they always say clearly
do i say clearly probably
i i probably do your honor he's clearly
guilty
your honor we should clearly win this
argument
[ __ ] new lawyers i was a new lawyer
so i can't really hate all though but
new lawyers do this all the time
this [ __ ] word clearly
right all the time this is all what they
do
destroying their credibility and
subsequently their audience and it
actually worked for a little while
preach are clearly intimidated by the
rise of fresh and fit the clearly
as an older attorney you say listen
take your brief back
if you redo it
if you bring me this briefing one more
time we're clearly in it
bring it to bring it to me bring it to
me one more time with clearly and see
what happens
don't say that it's not getting you
anywhere it's not getting you points
it's not getting you infants it's not
getting you anywhere in your argument
guys eliminate this from your vocabulary
instead of using clearly use evidence
[Laughter]
how about that
oh my god how about that instead of
using clearly use evidence
and
abbott and preach come on guys come on
does anybody think abba and preach are
intimidated by fresh and fit
yeah how many subscribers and how many
views would they need
to not
be intimidated by fresh and fit
if they had grown 500 000 subs
in a year
would then it be
i'm i'm not intimidated
where where is the line because if it's
a small youtuber
they definitely say oh it's because
they're hating on them
but now it's a bigger youtuber and you
see the same result
but why
even my dad my dad told me not to go on
that podcast which is so funny because
again my dad
most successful wise person i swear to
god i know
literally
told me not to go on but i still did and
listen
and i'm not i'm not even mad i went on i
put that video about why i would never
go on fresh and fit again
like people acted like it was such a big
deal
i've met the guys once i'm not a big
guest
i just wouldn't go on their show again i
didn't say i hated them i didn't say
they were bad people i said i wouldn't
go on your show show again and the crazy
thing is they had a comment and i
screenshotted it because i sold the
notification but it they deleted it and
like saying how i was fake
and i'm like it's not fake you screamed
at me after the show
and i didn't want to go on again
like
but this is like the weird thing about
the manosphere it's always them it's
never you it's always them
forget the fact
that
abba and preach have a channel that's
like three times the size
three times the size
they're clearly intimidated
this is what women say
no
he's intimidated by my phd he don't
[ __ ] want you
lose some weight
right
right
oh my god ain't nobody intimidated by
these [ __ ]
who are doing i mean listen 500 000
subscribers
they're killing the game
right they're killing the game
but come on
donovan i know they're your best friends
abbott and preach you've seen them
you've seen them these were these
canadian brothers on some other [ __ ]
do you see these brothers rocking like
uh iced out chains
you see them with the rubies and all
that you see them with that you guys
hear weird noises it's not me it's my
dog i have a bulldog look
okay emeralds
they're they're intimidated a freshman
come on man
come
on all right
talking about women
all right
when women feel like they're being
verbally attacked when women come up to
kevin's animals and he's trying to shove
some accountability up their [ __ ]
whether you know what where do what do
women kind of resort to
right
shout out to my man ola ola came up here
and talked about the sign language
gave us his gave us his impression and
gave us his his speech on what he
thought sign language was
right
but that's kind of the first place that
women that women go to
right now you know this would not be
juicy argument a juice and reaction
video without some damn sign language
it's here as an attorney guys this is
terrible i'm not holding him to an
attorney standard all right let me just
this is very educational i've learned a
lot about debate and arguments just from
watching this live stream
if he did like a video on how to debate
someone
and when or like errors people people
make in debates i would love to watch
that this is not a suzette type of thing
but we're just looking at it
all right let's take a look let's take a
look at what at what our man is saying
let's take a look
these two are too dumb to see what is
obvious these two words anyway let me
run that back again let me run that back
up when he says these two of course he's
talking about uh evan preach
are clearly intimidated by the rise of
fresh and fit these two are too dumb to
see what is obvious these all right did
somebody know you know ola had no idea
what the sign language meant if someone
says oh you're too dumb to understand
what letter
what letter in the sign language does
that correspond to right because the
sign language is really like an acronym
right now what you call it what is the
letter and then a period letter that
appears it's like acronym isn't that
right
you're just too dumb to understand
you're too dumb to get it
all right
i've been talking for
this monologue has gone on a little bit
have you seen me resort to any like uh
name calling
you don't have to do that guys you don't
got to do that
you can really stand on your arguments
you can stand them
i might have said
i might have said something about fresh
effect what did i say i might have said
something i don't know i might have
taken a shot i think i called them some
[ __ ]
these two [ __ ]
[Music]
it's not really it's not really an
insult though my my man my main man el
guapo he called me a [ __ ] and what is
his video
like do you see how big the lead
attorney is do you see how big this
[ __ ] is
so you know it's it's like the n-word
it's like tofu [ __ ] can kind of take
on the flavor of what's around it right
uh
but yeah
it's what is the people oh uh they say
it's the i
they say it's the eye from
stop
all right i for the insults
you guys are knowing it look at that
they're too stupid to know what's to
know what's
in the georgia accent donald probably
never been down to georgia
right
um
so you know not all right so here's the
thing here's the thing guys what is
donovan's kind of main point what is
what is the
main defense we're getting into the main
defense now you ready
we're getting into the main
presentation of the defense
the defense of his best friends
why
why are his best friends innocent of all
charges
why does abba have this wrong
why does preach have this wrong
why does the internet
you know forget dj academics and
everybody the whole internet has this
wrong
what's the real reason what's the what's
the motive behind donovan's
aggressive video
shut the [ __ ] up
why
well because you don't real you're too
dumb to realize what's going on let me
tell you what's going on what does
donovan say is going on let's hear it
let's hear what donovan says is going on
what's the what's the what's the behind
the scenes
fit these two are too dumb to see what
is obvious these two are too stupid to
realize
too stupid to realize the first time oh
wait i'm gonna wait i'm awake first
prince ceo was clearly just using this
girl to not only troll everyone but also
for content
okay when i first saw this that he's
like oh he was using any everybody i
thought that fresh prince was gonna
release a vlog where it was like a
behind the scenes of like oh this is a
prank on the manosphere da da da da i
didn't because i've done one of those
i've done like um
me and my boyfriend trolled
one time we really did break up for like
a little bit before i left for england
um but a different time we did not break
up but we made like videos and we would
go live and like talk about each other
and all this stuff and then um
then we put out a video later like
exposing the truth basically
and
it was just funny because
like i thought he was gonna do that but
no i don't
i didn't think it was oh
oh
okay okay oh now we get it did y'all
hear clearly again
[ __ ] would clearly i swear to god if
you say the word clearly to it to an old
attorney
clearly you just see the fists that
where's their fists
clearly using for content right clearly
trolling this is a troll
this is a troll
dj academics
everybody else
none of y'all saw it
he's clearly
trolling and for content all right let's
take a look at it again just so that you
know just so that we can get the get the
wording right
words mean something let's get it right
are too dumb to see what is obvious
these two are too stupid to realize wait
what's that again what is that
that's that's the sign language right
is that the sign language again jesus
christ
intimidated by the rise of fresh and fit
these two are too dumb to see what is
obvious these two are too stupid to
realize
too stupid to realize that fresh prince
ceo was clearly just using this girl to
not only troll everyone but also
for content okay
now we got it
this is interesting guys this is
interesting and i'll tell you why i'll
tell you why
it makes sense
that
our man
was
when he says when donovan sharp says
that this man was trolling and using
clearly using this stuff this whole
thing for content
it makes me think of another man
what was that dude's name
it makes me think of another man
who was a youtuber
and he was clearly trolling he was
clearly running experiments
what was that man's name
i saw him somewhere
i saw a man somewhere who said that he
was clearly just you know using uh
this this you know using these types of
tactics for for trolling using these
types of tactics for for for views using
it for content
he was using all of this for
experimentation
right trolling
what's that dudes
what was that dude's name i saw this
dude somewhere i saw him somewhere i'ma
think of his name in a second let me
think of his name in a second let's keep
going let's keep going
all right
this was oh [ __ ] part of a strategy oh
[ __ ] i don't know who will disagree with
me i think is working very fine to
launch the new mail channel let me not
to interrupt you but so
you're saying that this this um
the video that you've that you put out
first when you were in your your car
that was part of a strategy to launch
your your channel yes it's a muscle and
like i said i've had
people do four hour live streams about
me talking about me and i was like you
know i'm gonna try something a little
risque risque put it out there it was so
oh my god
i knew there was
i knew there was another dude was on the
tip of my
i knew there was another dude who was
trying stuff
for content
a little risque
to my new youtubers
do not do this [ __ ]
do not sell your credibility out for a
goddamn youtube channel
don't do it
you know
can you put out just good content
can you put out valuable content
is that possible
right
i mean is that possible
shout out to og wiz thank you so much og
wiz for becoming a member
shout out to dre
dugan sorry i missed it said let's so
let's do the debate donovan versus tla
and kevin samuels or mtr as the
moderator plaintiff versus defended the
chat is the jury this will benefit both
parties and show that men can still get
along and agree with okay
i wish i could pull this up
can i skip the super chat
um
okay back to it
oh we were talking about
using
your
platform
using your platform
for
craziness
right
like
guys
you
oh my gosh i've been going for an hour
and a half on here
i'm sorry lead attorney if you see this
i'm sorry i really only wanted to use
the donovan car
content
but
it just keeps
clearly trolling everybody
he's clearly doing this for content i
don't know how he feels about reactions
i think he said like you can
i don't let me know if i've crossed
anything in the comments i'll take it
down
fresh is clearly
doing things for content it sounds
familiar
[Laughter]
it sounds familiar
all right
let's keep going we'll do four hour live
streams about me talking about me and i
was like you know i'm gonna try
something a little risque i'm gonna put
it out there it was so convincing
all right now what are we talking about
now we're talking about the trolling
right the trolling
fresh uh
fresh is the short one right he's
trolling everybody
supposedly the short one
supposedly
i want to hear i want to hear what you
guys think about this argument all right
let's let's listen to it for a second
let's listen to what donovan says it was
so convincing
that the people around him actually
thought this thought was actually his
girl
but these two dumbasses fell for it
because they are pathetic desperate and
envious sign language did you hear the
sign language
pathetic desperate and envious
guys i want to show you all right
none of us are attorneys sorry
i think i'm the only one shout out to
susan speaks if she's in the house i've
actually had a few attorneys show up can
anybody identify the problem with this
argument
let's play a game let's do a quiz
who can identify the problem with this
argument here
ready go it was so convincing
that the people around him actually
thought this thought was actually his
girl
but these two dumbasses fell for it
because they are pathetic desperate and
envious all right so what's the art
what's the what's the
let's see if anybody could guess what's
the flaw in this argument what's the
flaw in this argument right put away put
put away for a second the fact
of the sign language yes there was a ton
of sign language there was a ton of sign
language
there was a ton of sign language in this
but what is the flaw
in this argument i know it's going to be
a little bit difficult for you because
it's kind of uh
it's kind of uh out of context right
it's kind of out of context but what's
the flaw it says sign language shaming
language it's not really the flaw it's
not really the flaw in the argument
i'm trying to look here clearly evidence
that he paid no
likes foundation you guys are getting
you guys are getting uh y'all gonna get
legal here let me show you let me tell
you with uh the um
yes
we got our winner
we got our winner shout out to mercury
double seven
you guys are ordering you don't have to
be attorneys
what is double 07 he said listen it's
contradicting
he called fresh and fi he called abba
and preach an idiot for being convinced
but he said it was so convincing yeah
oh my god he's so funny
shut up number you're exactly right not
only not only did he say it was so
convincing he said everybody was
convinced
everybody around fresh was convinced dj
akademik was convinced everybody who
heard this was convinced
these two dumbasses
they were convinced it's like totally
what are you talking about
right what are you talking about
absolutely right shout out to record
let's hear it again let's hear it again
a shout out i'm gonna start giving you
guys like uh
cash outs like twenty dollar cash
absolutely we're gonna play quizzes with
this it's so ridiculous
it was so convincing
that the people around him actually
thought this thought was actually his
girl
but these two dumbasses fell for it
because they are pathetic desperate and
envious
jesus christ
i love mercury shout out to mercury man
shout out to yes and it's true
there was some ad hominem bs as well
call it out bruce taylor
this is true
this is what you're putting up on your
channel
this this is the this is the value that
you're bringing to the youtube space
right
to all my i know i keep saying this but
it's so true
uh to my to my
to my younger youtubers do not treat
your channel like this
do not disrespect your channel like this
do not put out content like this that is
so many contradictions so many biases
where your credibility is just
it's your
you're murdering your own credibility in
front of
everybody in front of everybody
mercury was exactly right he said oh you
know
my man my best friend fresh because he
said they were best friends
my best friend fresh he was so
convincing at trolling he trolled
everybody
fresh got all of you he trolled
everybody
fresh got all of you he got dg academics
he got all the girls in the studio he
got mike rashid fresh got everybody
he was so good my best friend is so good
at trolling
but you dumbasses
you two dumbasses believe that was like
what the hell
this is a really good way to break down
arguments unemotionally honestly
arguments that we're making
guys
let's keep it going let's keep it going
what does he say what does he say what
does he say let's keep it
going passes
fell for it because they are pathetic
desperate and envious abba this is why
you're a [ __ ] jesus
fresh is true oh wow jesus troll like
this is it dude this is this is so
obvious do you here we go
it's so clearly it's so obvious
clearly
you don't know what that does to an
attorney
clint like if you want to get on an
attorney's nerve just keep saying
clearly over and over and over again
clearly
if it was so obvious
then how did he have everybody convinced
if he's if he's so
if fresh is clearly
obviously trolling
donovan how did he have everybody
convinced it's not making sense
it's not making sense
i actually thought this thought was
actually his girl
but these two
will do
jesus let me get this man off my screen
sensing
that the people around him actually
thought this thought was actually his
girl
but these two dumbasses fell for it
because they are pathetic desperate and
envious abba this is why you're a
[ __ ] idiot hey
fresh is trolling you you idiot sign
language like this is dude this is this
is so obvious
so which one is it
i have donovan on my channel tomorrow
i didn't
i could have asked him about this stuff
but when i came up with the show topic i
didn't do this and i feel like
i gotta stop saying i feel like
i
would imagine he's gonna already have a
response to this on his channel because
it's going pretty viral right now
so
i don't know maybe i'll email we'll see
we'll see is it is it that did he have
everybody in the world convinced
or was it so obvious that he was
trolling that no one was convinced
was everybody convinced because it was
so non-obvious
or were abba and preach
idiots because it was so obvious are you
guys picking this up how can it be so
obvious
and not obvious at the same time
because you don't have to be an attorney
to see this this is [ __ ] ridiculous
and and if you are an attorney and
you're listening to these arguments
you're like
jesus christ
speak
let me stop the show for a second
let me stop the show for a second
[Music]
y'all don't know who this
y'all don't know who this beautiful lady
is
shawn tale thank you
let me hit it again
i'm not i'm not big like kevin sanders
kevin samuels get a damn thousand dollar
super chat keep rocking
[Music]
we got to stop the show over here
we're going to skip the
okay i think the absolute sponsor of
this
but is the same time y'all certainly can
uh yeah both if y'all want to come up
but just just give me just give me
something and chantelle chantel richards
and please guys go
okay now we're going back
why why is he just quiet i must have
he must have said something i'm gonna
keep going
oh wait no did i miss something okay
wait let me go back
okay here we go that's cute i like that
shout out like i always supported your
boy
okay i was like he's too quiet he had to
have said something funny but thank you
again chantelle chantel richards and
please guys go check out foreverfresh
thank you for sponsoring this uh this
man's day stream
i really do appreciate it
all right so now we uh
we we
we saw the level of argument that
donovan has
we saw that right how somebody does he
have hashtag white girls
in the back
why
so obvious
but you know your boy fresh was fresh
was trolling so good that everybody saw
it
including
abba and preach
but ava and preach are the dumb ones
because only those two were were
convinced it didn't make any sense let's
hear it
it was so convincing
that the people around him actually
thought this thought was actually his
girl
but these two dumbasses
fell for it because they are pathetic
desperate and envious but this is why
you're a [ __ ]
fresher's trolling you you sign language
like this is it dude this is this is so
obvious yeah do you all right
take a breath are you ready let's keep
going
see this all right so all right let's
get let's move on for a second
so we already know what type of
arguments that we're dealing with all
right but
i'm you know
let's put that to assad
new argument all right let's come up
with a new argument let's see let's see
where we're at this is the manosphere
we're supposed to be strong brothers
over here
we're supposed to be taking
we're supposed to be taken seriously
over here
you already see kevin samuels
right he's not [ __ ] around with with
with anybody he's he's being taken
he is being taken seriously he's
everywhere he's mainstream now
a lot of you new youtubers y'all have
500 subscribers y'all have 1300
subscribers you're trying to be taken
seriously i'm the same way
we're all in this together
if you're going to make good arguments
make them
we haven't heard
any good arguments yet
but you know let's let's keep going
let's keep going all right i'm sure
there's some in here let's go what do we
got
yes yeah do you see this
fresh is trolling all of them
abba you have abba you have tits as a
man
what
yes you have male
breasts
i'm just gonna put that out there what
oh this is why he was quiet
we're gonna keep going
we're gonna keep going
why in the world would fresh commit to
this miami thought after all of this
content
now
this is actually a great point
this is actually a great point that your
voice says he says listen
why would fresh commit to a girl
right why would he why do why would he
commit to one girl
he's he's got all of this content
showing that he's a player he's got all
of these content showing that he's
having sex with you know multiple women
in nba players mansions
[Laughter]
it would make no sense for him
to say that he is just with one
girlfriend now guys i don't know if you
could if
the whole thing is about fresh heaven
uh simping for a girlfriend that's like
only fans and sugar dad sugar baby and
all that
this is actually a great point that
donna is saying he's got all of this
content
why that's what i thought when i first
watched it was
he probably wasn't taking her seriously
that was my first thought could he
make a video
reneging on all of that right
let's hear let's hear what he says again
let's see what he says again
i'm just going to put that out there why
in the world would fresh commit to this
miami thought after all of this content
so what is donovan saying he's like
listen this man built his whole
the damn podcast on being player player
in the himalayas with the lambo and the
rolly shout out to playing jane
why would he commit to just one
all right
that seems like a good argument it is a
good argument but here's the thing what
happens
when you're biased
what happens when your mama takes the
stand in your defense
your mama's not going to see both sides
she's biased
i'm telling you this is a 20-year
attorney i've seen mothers on the stand
they're biased
what happens when your co-defendant
turns states evidence
and takes a plea deal so that he gets
probation but you get 10 years to serve
both of y'all were gonna get eight years
to serve he turned on you you're getting
ten he's getting straight probation he's
going home tonight
he's biased
he's not gonna see both sides
right
what happens when your best friends
receive an apology from you
because you didn't stand up for him in
the summer like you thought you should
even though no one else did
except for rollo and he was basically
whatever um
no one else really stood up for him
because they were [ __ ]
up and manosphere's about responsibility
it's about
admitting your mistakes it's about
accountability
but you went
and apologized to your best friends
for not standing up for their [ __ ] [ __ ]
fine
well now that you're your best friends
maybe you're not seeing
the whole thing that clearly
so what does donald jose's like listen
guys
fresh is the guy the ceo he is the one
having sex with all of these women he's
banging four girls at a time
he's got the lambos he's got the ice
right how could he ever just settle down
for one girl
how
now i think donovan's right on here
right it wouldn't make sense like
there's no way there's no way
that fresh
could settle down and just choose one
girl
you know
he must be right donovan must be right
about this
let's see
yes you have male breasts
i'm just gonna put that out there why in
the world would fresh commit to this
miami thought after all of this content
i agree i agree there's no way that he
could just settle
in bro i supposed to mr organic on the
phone bro at this point bro
mutt dude you got some bro when you're
just a certain level you can't move the
same of you
same way that you used to move
so enough me bro
i ain't trying to mess with these girls
bro oh
couple tricks i'm cool with that are
solid or maybe one two
three who knows maybe one
of me bro are you listening to this
listen to what he does oh first of all
shout out to mr organic i don't know who
that is but you know what he said he
said listen i spoke to mr organic
hung up and now it's all clear what the
hell did mr organic tell you
did he tell you the same thing lead
attorney's been telling you since day
one
did mr organic tell you the same thing
they're in the the lead attorney's
videos i spoke listen to what he says i
spoke to mr organic
and now
you know you can't move the way you used
to once you read a certain level listen
to what he says he's like man no for
real i might just go one chick
then i'm gonna go two well maybe two
chicks then he's like well he gets
greedy right or maybe i'll go to three
chicks and then he gets smart he goes
one chick two chicks three women and
then once he do he's like no no one
woman listen to it
the conviction in this man's voice oh my
god he's so funny listen to him he goes
one woman two woman three woman no one
woman one woman
at this point bro
my dude you got some bro when you're
just a certain level you can't move the
same way you the same way that you used
to move really enough me bro
i ain't trying to mess with these girls
in the streets bro i want like a couple
tricks on kuwait that are solid or maybe
one two one two three who knows maybe
one maybe one
white
guys i don't know what to tell you
what does donovan say no this is fresh
no he would never settle down
how could you think fresh would settle
down over all of this content he's got
all of this content
why would you think he would only have
one girl
what did fresh say in august
what did fresh say in august
he said i spoke to mr organic
and mr organic told me once you reach a
certain level you can't move the way you
used to
so
now i only want one girl
donald is like how can you what do you
mean he only wants one girl what did
fresh say in the summer i only want one
girl
then he's like no no maybe two women
no no no maybe three no no [ __ ] one
girl one girl
give me one girl oh my god
you heard him out of his own goddamn
mouth donovan
[Music]
you said y'all are best friends how do
you not know this
i have a question donovan was he
trolling you
was he trolling everybody
in august like he's trolling everybody
now you said
that
he made a five-hour stream where he was
transparent
do you know where that clip came from
you want to guess
you want to guess where that clip came
from
from that five hour stream
where he was transparent guys
oh my god
i don't i really would love to see
donovan respond to this because i just
don't even know how you could
this man
has got you at every angle every single
angle oh leader turning you need to
debate donovan like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
[Music]
what are you talking about
[Music]
i mean that's not an insult but it's
like come on
donovan sharp is telling us how this
five hour stream he was so transparent
and in that same five hour stream fresh
said he wanted one girl
now in november's donovan is like how do
you think fresh only one's one girl look
at all the content how do you think
fresh only wants one girl i don't know
donald trump
i don't know oh my god i don't know
where i got that crazy idea from
you know
and this is the problem with blind
loyalty sometimes you can you're not
really doing your friends any favors
right
who in the chat thinks that fresh and
fit really wanted donovan to do this
video i mean we know why donovan did it
donovan was like these are my best
friends
i had to apologize to them for acting
like a [ __ ]
for not defending them so now i have a
chance to defend them
fresh and fit we're like no no you good
you
you're good
all of these contradictions
all of these non-sequiturs all of these
biases where's your credibility you're
defending us you have no credibility
you're good donovan
donovan was like no no no let me get him
let me get him
alvin preach need to shut the [ __ ] up
who would think that fresh only wants
one girl what about all of the content
there's no way he's only gonna want one
girl
this is ridiculous
now
i haven't heard let's just be honest i
haven't heard donovan say any not one
not one good argument
not one
clearly i have not heard one good
argument
but
and why because you know he's being
biased because he's his best friends but
let's be fair some of you could be like
hey lee aren't you biased against
donovan how am i going to be biased
against donovan he's come on my show
multiple times
some of you might not know this donovan
was on my show for an hour on friday
all right
do you hear me calling donovan assam do
you hear me calling him a [ __ ] do you
hear me calling him stupid no i'm not
taking shots at the man
i'm talking about his arguments
but before you jump off the ledge this
is the same thing that i did to
suzette speaks who is an attorney
this ain't this ain't beef
i have a lane
it's bringing a 20-year attorney
perspective to your ass that's what i'm
doing
i brought it with sues that speaks do it
to donovan i did a response video to
that crazy tasha k video
and then i made another video about
tasha k
even though in the hey man
she's wild
but i'm not i can't be silenced i gotta
keep going
and hopefully i'm showing you guys
things that you have not considered
yeah he is but i too want to be fair
if he has good points i want to
acknowledge him he does have a good
point what's the good point that he has
listen
let's be serious for a second
no [ __ ] emojis
i didn't know this until i saw donovan
sharp's video
fresh has
apparently has a stuttering problem
all right
apparently that's a stuttering problem
albert there's a point in one of in in
this november aven preach video where
they make fun of his stuttering problem
they make fun of the way he's speaking
they don't make fun of the fact that he
stutters they might not know that he's
stu he has a stuttering problem
but they do make fact they do make fun
of the way that he's speaking
right
let's let's hear let's hear it for a
second
let's hear it
pull this up
in the world would fresh commit to this
miami thought after all of this content
if you don't get the [ __ ] out okay all
right here we go
is that what you said
all of this content you don't get the
[ __ ] all right get ready
this is about the stuttering issue that
fresh has and guys people are born with
let me just put this back up
guys listen people are born with
stuttering problems
um you could have been born with the
stuttering problem i could have been
born with the stuttering problem there
are some adults who do oh my god this
just reminded me of this time in high
school where this girl had a lisp but it
wasn't like i have a little one you
could probably hear it the s's i don't
do well with them but this girl had
one where the w's instead of like want
she'd be like oh my god i can't do it
like like a baby though that's how it
sounded like
i was like wobble
i don't know i can't do it but anyways
she
the teacher was like asking her like why
she talks that way in front of the whole
class
it was the most cringe-worthy thing
that's ever happened no no i've there's
been a lot of cringe-worthy things not
beat it
so
what he's bringing up is a real point
all right let's take a look at it let's
listen
dumbass whoa
is that being sad but anyways let us
know what you guys okay so now we're
going to make so now we're going to make
fun of the way a [ __ ] talks we're going
to make fun of somebody's speech
impediment fam
and guys again anybody could have a
speech impediment
like look man like look dude look bro
like i understand
these guys don't like meyer and fresh
like i get it i get it and they can go
back and forth and do whatever but
really gonna make fun of the way a [ __ ]
talks
right you're gonna sit there you're
gonna sit there and make fun of
somebody's stuttering problem mr moral
cathedral
mr
you know i'm mr moralistic on high but
you're gonna make fun of the way you're
gonna make fun of somebody's [ __ ]
stuttering problem
now listen
let me pull this back up
um
he's right about that
guys and again we talked about this
before anybody
anybody could be born with a stuttering
problem give me one second and i should
have done this before but i'm in my flow
but i have to uh
i have to uh
acknowledge
the sponsor of the show thank you so
much to uh again chantal richards please
go support um
[Music]
everfresh
forever fresh all right
your speech impediment is something that
you um
you can't control
and so
that could absolutely it's a [ __ ] low
blow
all right
it's a [ __ ] low blow
so
i agree with donovan on that point like
no one no one should be making fun of
the way that someone speaks
you know the way someone speaks is how
they speak
so
no one should be making fun of the way
someone talks all right let's keep going
what the [ __ ] was that hold up
oh
what was that
i love it
whatever whatever what looks like the
tick tock sound what what was that no
let's keep going
let's keep going let's go all right next
point
let's just watch never forget this man
has a thousand body counts okay
wait a minute
i thought making fun of the way someone
spoke was off limits
wait a minute
i know i'm an attorney
is it is it me though i mean
all right
that was
i must be maybe i'm re i'm an attorney
i'm reading too much into it right
that's me
as far as um you yeah you're definitely
something
i thought i thought
leaving someone's the way they speak i
thought that was off limits
it's so funny because he's so nice
but
like this is the most respectful roast i
have ever seen like he does not miss he
does not miss on a single point
we weren't gonna make fun of the way
someone sounds
this is the content you are putting out
as a grown man in the man of sphere this
is the content
these are the arguments and you wonder
why chantal laughing at us
you wonder why april mason just come on
here and say all types of [ __ ]
alba has tits
i don't know guys
i thought making fun of the way someone
speaks was off limits
i guess i just i just [ __ ] misheard
it
i just misheard it i'm [ __ ] on me
whatever
dumbasses whoa this is your alpha male
dating coach
god damn like come on
what are we doing
i mean
how many times is he gonna make fun of
the way i've been preacher speaking
like again
jesus christ
jesus christ
oh
i don't know what to
i don't know what to say about whatever
where is your credibility if you
contradict yourself throughout your
video where is your credibility
where is your reputation where is your
standing
where is it
that's the one thing about
having a youtube channel is sometimes
i don't want to say it's hard to stay
credible because
you know like i'm always honest and i'm
always transparent on here but sometimes
i'll say something and think like have i
contradicted that before because my
opinion changed on this topic
because i'll think back to like a video
i made six months ago and i'm like oh
i like think differently than that now
but whatever
let's leave the contradictions behind us
all right let's move
this on is
what is there to say
i mean
i don't know if you noticed this guys
and let me just make it very clear
that was not one clip played over and
over and over
every single clip in there was different
than the clip before
just to make it clear
the hypocrisy
guys sometimes you'll be representing
somebody and they'll be on the stand and
y'all have already prepped for trial and
you've told them what to say and they
practiced it and they just get up and
they just start wilding out
start talking about [ __ ] and you're
standing there trying to look like yeah
you know what's you know what they're
talking about you don't know what
because they're not making sense and
they're killing the whole
case
let me try to rehabilitate donovan
let me try to support him
because it's not looking good
i think he's so nice donovan was saying
that
abba and preet should not make fun
of the way fresh and fit speed
now donovan
sharp
later made so
many
so much fun of the way that alvin preach
were speaking he also like insulted his
wife
he he said something along the lines of
i'm not gonna bring his wife and do it
but like very much insinuating that his
wife is not cute
but fine let's put
let's put donovan to a side
listen to where i'm going
let's put donovan to assad for a second
donova is not really in it
he is so good at not using
like um
and speaking very
professionally
that's where i lack
i say like so much oh my gosh
and oh my gosh and just random like
see i did it i did it again
i'm gonna let him go because this is
between
the the making fun of the speech is
between abba and preach
and fresh and fit so you know let's
let's give donovan license to make fun
because he's out of it who's in it
and preach fresh and fit fresh and fit
abba and preach
so
no one should be making fun
as between those two groups
no one should be making fun of how
someone else speaks as between them
all right no one
that's what we're gonna go with okay
we got that donovan can make fun of the
way people speak but those two groups
i'm trying to help him out is difficult
he's [ __ ] the case up
[ __ ] up our case
but let's just say between those two
groups
no one should make fun of the way people
speak
all right jesus
let's just end it there all right what's
what's
what's next
let me play this shout out to tom
sotomayor this beautiful bean footage
the wife is probably ugly i said it
yo you gave her a ring pop and you
licked her at your [ __ ] wedding
we should fly around bro weirdo we
should fire up guarantee
flute
wait a minute
wait a goddamn minute
bro that's the thing but it's just
because everyone's jealous of them right
it's the jealousy
not only
is fresh and fit making fun of the way
that someone sounds
they are making fun of the way
preach sounds
donovan what the [ __ ] are you what the
[ __ ] are you talking about look at your
arguments
abba and preach
cannot make fun of the way fresh and fit
sound in november
when in august
fresh and fit we're making fun of the
way
preach talked we're making fun of the
way preacher's wife looked we're making
fun of the way preached move like a
monkey like an ape damn
look at his [ __ ] hands
look at myron when he's impersonating
preach look at
like a [ __ ]
gorilla
no one was talking about this but me and
i don't know maybe it's i'm from the
[ __ ] south
and i'm a little sensitive to race
issues y'all saw that's what i was
thinking that
isn't that racist
in the damn aubry
reaction that i did
but i thought donovan said making fun of
the way someone sounds was off limits
and here we have with this [ __ ]
right
let's let's see what he says oh hey yo
we should fire up guarantee
flute
the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
oh god
we [ __ ] help guys make money we help
guys get in shape we help men improve
what the [ __ ] are you dumbass [ __ ]
doing behind your shitty ass road
shotgun mike
yo
oh
look at the white girl i could tell you
[ __ ] think from the [ __ ] video i'm
watching right now they'll be sweating
in the [ __ ] studio
and y'all standing matt awkwardly close
to each other talking to that shitty ass
mike hey we're gonna take on this preach
the [ __ ] man [ __ ] is this
look at the white girl laughing
shout out to the white girl this is
shout out to tasha k listen i don't know
what to tell you guys
about this
okay i'm gonna end the
video there because he actually goes on
to have preach on the channel or no not
preach abba and it's actually a really
interesting conversation so i'm going to
link the video and if you guys want to
watch it um watch the full thing on his
channel because
oh my god you will not regret it
i mean if you watched it this far
like
just finish it finish it on his channel
because oh my god
i could not believe that [ __ ] was free
that was so funny um let me know in the
comments what you guys think don't
forget to subscribe to the channel
please subscribe like if you've watched
three of my videos or more and you
haven't subscribed yet we got beef
help a girl out okay
i'll talk to you later